le froid qui est une aubaine pour la
petite station chinoise de la planche
des belles filles
cela fait dix ans qu'on n'y avait pas
skier au cette période de fin d'année
ainsi vers que la planche n'avait pas vu
ça des belles filles i sur ses fils en
décembre l'an passé il avait fallu
attendre la neige et cédric et pour
ouvrir encore 20 cm en haut pour
l'instant la petite station c'est
presque de l'ombre où tout proche ballon
d'alsace
aussi quand ils rentrent au delà des
gens n'ont pas la place est depuis 20
ans la station est plutôt sur la bonne
pente
ici la saison ne dure que 30 jours en
moyenne le forfait est le plus bas des
vosges 70 francs la journée mais avec
onze mille skieurs par an cinq pistes
trois téléskis cette personne la planche
est tout sauf un complexe donc au
problème la planche ne fait pas de
complexe nous avons eu notre clientèle
et urbaines ratej éloigner ce qui nous
permet d'avoir une clientèle jeune
à 1948 mètres d'altitude seulement les
skieurs peuvent voir les alpes et salé
c'est plutôt sourire respect comme pour
pas trouvé mieux avec le soleil tous les
boss qu'on vous a pu voir ces 1000 dans
les alpes
moi je trouve puisque en fait je
recherche que les ibos donc moi dans les
alpes c'est beaucoup de pistes
donc j'aimerais ici pour faire du souk
avec 40000 francs la planche des belles
filles s'est tracé une nouvelle piste
pour 97 en toute modestie comme le ski